[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREW BROGDON: When
you register an app
and create an ad
unit in the AdMob UI,
you get not one
but two ID values--
an app ID and an ad unit ID.
So what are those and
how are they used?
Well, an app ID is
a unique identifier
for an app using AdMob.
They're one-to-one.
The value doesn't
change, and its main use
is in the call to
initialize the mobile ads
SDK when your app launches.
An ad unit ID represents
a spot within an app
where you might show an ad.
That could be a location
in your interface where
a banner's going to be or one
of the moments in the flow
of your app where you'd like
to show a rewarding video ad,
such as at the end
of each game level.
It's basically an
instance in space or time
where you'd like the
option of showing an ad.
That's an ad unit.
By having different
IDs for your ad units,
you can track and report
on them separately
and use different
mediation groups,
depending on what's generating
the best revenue for you.
So there you go.
App ID is for a whole
app, and an ad unit ID
is for a spot within that app
where you'd like to show an ad.
[MUSIC PLAYING]